um I don't understand when girls say  like I'm an eight because or sometimes I  hear girls say time because I hear this  a lot where they say like because I love  myself and I'm like confident now but  don't you think attractiveness is based  on results  and I may be but I don't care about  those results  to be honest  but do you think then you're not being  objective about your how attractive you  are or how attractive anyone else might  be  um  I guess not but like yeah  that stuff's not really important to me  but I think when when someone when  someone rates somebody why why does that  have anything to do with them like if  you rate me if someone rated like  somebody or three and it's just like  okay that's that's your opinion like  it's not like a rating it's not a fact  it's an opinion what do you know what I  mean everyone